protests of course continued over the
weekend and i feel like i begin
every monday uh with that sentence
protests continued
probably isn't necessary at this point
to say it um and it probably isn't
necessary either
to do this but i will anyway here's a
very quick montage
showing some of what happened uh in
portland over the weekend watch this
[Applause]
if that looked like a bible they were
burning that's because it was a bible we
have now officially reached the book
burning phase of things
but i suspect that anyone who has
remained sympathetic to the protesters
through all of this will not be
disturbed by by this development of
book burning um you know sure i'll i'll
align myself with book burners no
problem because
that always works out well historically
right now
nothing to be disturbed about here um
but the incident from this weekend that
i i really want to focus on is
this little exchange down in austin
protesters were once again blocking the
roads just
sort of standing aimlessly in the street
as they do
interfering with people's lives simply
for the sake of interfering
and then a black man drove up who
apparently didn't have time
for their nonsense
friends
i got bills i got kids i got to go to
work he raises a good point doesn't he
and that in that point again raises a
question often posed about these
protesters which is
do these people have jobs apparently not
i mean they're out in the street every
single day for weeks on end holding
signs
it's hard to see how they could be
gainfully employed in the midst of all
of that so
we have a bunch of people who aren't
really contributing to society who
aren't productive
adult members of society but who
nonetheless expect us to listen to their
political views and take them seriously
my question is why should we why should
we take them seriously
now granted the government has put
millions of people out of work with a
series of some of the
worst policy decisions we've seen
certainly in modern times anyway
and you could always use that as an
excuse for them
it's not their fault that they're
unemployed and you know and um
they have nothing else to do and and
that's all goes back to the government
you might argue
but i don't fully buy that excuse
because for one thing if you did lose
your job because of the lockdowns
i would think you'd probably be spending
your time pursuing other job
opportunities rather than protesting
but for another more to the point
perhaps this is not a new thing the left
has a never-ending supply of people who
have nothing to do but protest
and this is something that easily
predates the pandemics you can't really
blame it on that
how quickly quickly we all forget it was
only back last fall that
environmentalist wackos
you remember this they were they were
doing the same thing all over the
country
um and in other countries too standing
in the middle of the street blocking
traffic
sometimes even blocking trains from
going by commuter trains
this went on for weeks um there was no
pandemic there was no shutdown then
and there wasn't a pandemic or a
shutdown back when we had the first
round of blm protests starting with the
uh
justified killing of the violent
criminal michael brown
so while the shutdowns are no doubt a
contributing factor the fact remains
simply that shutdowns or no there is a
sizable portion of the american public
that apparently can afford to spend
their days doing
activism because someone else
mommy and daddy perhaps or uncle sam
maybe one of those family members
is supporting them and funding their
lifestyles
what we find in that video that i just
played and in so many other
videos like it that we've seen is the
stark divide between
on the one hand people who have nothing
to offer
society who are just standing in the
street getting in everybody's way and
calling that activism
and on the other hand the people who
actually keep the country going
the people like that man in the car the
people who pay all the taxes support
families
and do all of the actual work sustaining
and maintaining
maintaining a human society now i guess
we're supposed to believe or pretend to
believe
that both groups have equally valid and
important points of view and that
both groups should be listened to and
taken seriously but i disagree
i'm not really interested in what the
latter group in fact i should say i'm
only really interested in what the
latter group
the real grown-ups have to say
and that brings us to i think a related
issue mail-in voting
you know president trump has obviously
been on a tear recently making a fuss
about all the states that are planning
to push mail-in voting
for the election in november uh the
primary concern trump seems to have
about this
the primary concern that that many on
the right have about this
is voter fraud and i understand that
concern i think that there's validity to
it
um but i also think that the right wing
obsession with voter fraud
kind of misses the point and is in a way
an easy out
a more politically correct route around
the real issue with voting and with our
democratic process
as it currently functions the real
problem with voting
and i've argued this many times and this
is by extension the problem even more so
with mail-in voting
is that there are too many people doing
it and it's too easy to do
this has already been the case with
voting in general mail-in voting will
only
exacerbate the ever-present problem
if voting is not important enough to you
if it's not enough of a priority
to expend any real effort to do it
then you shouldn't be voting at all your
voice is not needed and would probably
do more harm than good in the voting
booth anyway
and if you are a non-contributing
ignoramus someone who has
no real stake in society and who
contributes nothing of substance to it
who is not productive
and who knows nothing about our system
then
you should not be able to participate in
it at least in the capacity of a voter
you know voting ought to be a privilege
reserve for informed
grown-up contributing members of society
if you aren't paying taxes then you
shouldn't have any say in where tax
money
other people's money goes and if you are
woefully
ignorant of even the most basic facts of
our system
then you shouldn't be able to by
wandering into a voting booth or worse
by by mail from your home muddy the
waters by
randomly casting a ballot ignorantly
with no idea of what you're even doing
you know we don't let people drive on
highways that way
why should we let them drive the
republic that way the consequences after
all are just as dire if not
considerably more so now
i wouldn't advocate for taking first
amendment rights away from protesters
who are ignorant non-contributing
dummies
as tempting of a thought as that might
be at times no they have the right to
speak their mind of course
but they don't have the right to do it
in the middle of the highway but
and they don't have the right to do it
while throwing miles off cocktails
but my concern is that the attitude
we're told we're supposed to have
towards these protesters the idea that
their opinion is just as valid as
anybody else's
also makes its way into the voting booth
um and it shouldn't
you know if you're not an informed
tax-paying citizen willing to expend a
minimal effort
to uh you know to register your vote
middle
minimal effort meaning just leaving your
home on one particular day
going to a polling place and voting then
you shouldn't be allowed to vote
ignorant non-contributing non-productive
people
can march through the city annoying
everyone as is their right
but they shouldn't have the right to to
dictate the direction of the country
via the ballot box and this is why there
should be some very basic restrictions
to determine who can vote
voting should be reserved for people who
are tax paying adults
and adults these days probably means
more like 25 instead of 18
with extended adolescence being a real
issue as well so tax paying adults who
can pass a basic sixth grade civics exam
that's my that's my proposal uh these
restrictions would not exclude anyone
based on
basic facts about their biolog
biological identity which they can't
control or change
obviously excluding people from voting
based on sex race ethnicity is wrong and
illegal and should be
but excluding people based on behavior
and choices
is another thing altogether voting
is not a god-given right endowed by the
creator and meant to be shared by all
people
no matter what we already restrict
voting based on several factors
and not all factors that actually a
person can change
as it stands right now if you're seven
years old
you can't vote uh if you're a convicted
serial killer
you can't vote most people now the left
is trying to change
both both of those okay they're going
way in the other direction
and as always the left has no problem
advocating for things that seem radical
and in fact are radical
until they don't seem radical anymore
because they get their way so they're
they're they're just gonna they're gonna
go you know they're gonna shoot for the
mountaintops all the time
and so now there are leftists who would
say yeah oh yeah convicted serial
killers should vote from prison
um if they're even in prison if they're
if we even keep them in prison at all
uh children should vote
maybe eventually the right will learn to
to do the same
thing rather than constantly you know
move as as the left moves the culture
moves the you know as they're as they
are advocating for the most extreme
leftist position
they move the mainstream position left
with them
and what the right always does is they
move along with the mainstream position
they always want to stay there in the
mainstream because they say well if
we're too radical no one's going to
listen
but the right should be responding with
the opposite say no
no no no this is this is not this is not
how we
how how you run a functioning society
by trying to involve literally everyone
in the voting process even to the point
where eventually yes they're going to
have 12 year olds out there voting
as it stands right now though
most people who are not radical leftists
would say now probably if i were to make
a guess about what most people in the
mainstream would think
everything i've said so far many people
the mainstream would think that's too
extreme that's
even horrific and horrible how dare you
voting is a sacred right and
how dare you say these things uh yet i
would also guess
most of those people would say that well
sure we're not going to have 12 year
olds vote
why not though why don't we have 12 year
olds vote
if you're not in favor of 12 year olds
voting why it's
and don't it's not enough to say oh
they're minors what does that have to do
with anything who cares if they're
minors
we call them minors fine but what is it
about them
that should exclude them from voting
could i suggest what it might be
um i think it's that they're not
productive contributing members
tax-paying members of society and they
don't know a damn thing about the system
they are ignorant and non-productive now
when they're 12 that's not their
fault all 12 year olds are that way 12
year olds are supposed to be that way
um but so
if if we exclude 12 year olds on that
basis
why shouldn't we exclude 32 year olds on
that basis
so if the 12 year old we say the 12 year
old you can't vote because they're
ignorant and non-contributing
and then when they turn 18 even if
they're still ignorant and
non-contributing we say okay you can
vote now
why why don't we just let them vote when
they were 12 in that case what's the
difference
so i do think this is a discussion we
should be having more often in in if
we're going to be talking about
you know problems with our voting system
rather than focusing all the time on
voter fraud voter fraud voter fraud
i think this is the real sort of fraud
that's being perpetuated on our system
and we should be talking about it hey
you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated